>> Tucker: EIGHT YEARS AGO, A
PENTAGON COMMUNITY CALLED THE
DEFENSE SCIENCE BOARD ISSUED A
STERN WARNING.
THE CYBER THREAT IS SERIOUS THEY
WROTE WERE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES SIMILAR TO THE
NUCLEAR THREAT OF THE COLD WAR.
A DECADE LATER, DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE THE GOVERNMENT IS TAKING
THE THREATS AS SERIOUSLY AS THEY
PROMISED THEY WOULD.
NOW THE THREATS HAVE MULTIPLIED.
WHEN HACKERS SHUT DOWN THE GAS
SUPPLY TO THE EASTERN SEABOARD,
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID IT WAS A
PRIVATE MATTER.
WATCH HOW JOE BIDEN'S TOP
SPOKESWOMAN REACTED TO A HACK OF
250,000 SERVERS OPERATED BY
MICROSOFT.
MICROSOFT SAYS THE HACK CAME
FROM CHINA.
HERE'S HOW THE WHITE HOUSE
RESPONSES.
>> IN MARCH WE HEARD FROM JAKE
SULLIVAN.
HE SAID THE U.S. IN THE NEAR
FUTURE WOULD NAME WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE HACK ON THE
MICROSOFT EXCHANGE.
SO CAN YOU TELL US WHO THAT IS?
SEVERAL MONTHS HAVE PASSED AND
WHAT THE HOLD-UP IS.
>> I'LL CHECK WITH OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE AN UPDATE.
THEY'RE CAREFUL AND THOROUGH.
THOROUGH IS PROBABLY THE RIGHT
WORD ON HOW THEY REVIEW AND
ASSESS PUBLIC GUIDANCE.WE'LL SEE
IF THERE'S ANYTHING MORE.
>> THE THEORY THAT IT'S CHINA OR
CAN YOU NOT GO FURTHER?
>> I DON'T HAVE AN UPDATE FROM
WHAT WE PROVIDED IN THE PAST.
>> Tucker: THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO
IS NOT COMMENTING ON NEWS TODAY
THAT HACKERS WITH TIES TO CHINA
TRIED TO HACK NEW YORK'S SUBWAY
SYSTEM IN APRIL OF THIS YEAR.
THE INTERESTING THING IS THAT
NOT AT HACKS GET THIS TREATMENT.
SEE IF YOU CAN SPOT THE
DIFFERENCE WHEN ANOTHER COUNTRY
IS INVOLVED.
WATCH.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN THINKS THAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN
STOPPING AND PREVENTING THE
ATTACKS.
HENCE IT'S A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION
WHEN THEY MEET IN TWO WEEKS.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
EXACTLY?
SINCERE QUESTION.
GLEN GREEN
GREENWALD H.
THESE CYBER ATTACKS WERE
DEPENDENT ON THE INTERNET.
THE RESPONSES FROM OFFICIAL
WASHINGTON ARE PUZZLING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THEM?
>> IT'S OBVIOUSLY BIZARRE IN THE
SENSE THAT WE'RE CONSTANTLY
TALKING ABOUT OUR MASSIVE
DEFENSE BUDGET.
WE SPEND TEN TIMES MORE ON
DEFENSE THAN THE NEXT 12
COUNTRIES COMBINED.
IT IS RUN THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE, CONSTANTLY THIS
WORLD IS INVOKED TO JUSTIFIED
THESE HUGE BUREAUCRACIES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DEFENSE
BUDGET, IT'S NOT ABOUT DEFENSE.
PROTECTING OUR FOOD SUPPLY AND
ENERGY SUPPLY FROM ACTUAL HACKS.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE OF IT THAT
IS SPENT ON THAT.
YOU SEE THIS OVER AND OVER.
WHEN I DID THE REPORTING IN
2013, WHICH IS ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
AGO WHEN THAT REPORT CAME OUT,
$75 BILLION WAS SPENT ON THE
INTELLIGENCE BUDGET.
ALMOST ALL ON SPYING ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS, HACKING INTO THE
SYSTEMS OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
NONE WAS SPENT ON HOW TO DO
DEFENSE, DEFENDING OUR OWN
COUNTRY.
EVEN IN RUSSIA GATE, ALL THE
HYSTERIA ABOUT THE RUSSIANS
ATTACKING OUR ELECTION SYSTEM,
TULSI GABBARD SAID IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT IT, PASS THIS BILL
TO PROVIDE PAPER BALLOTS TO MAKE
SURE THERE WAS NO HACKING.
THERE WAS NO INTEREST IN THAT.
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A REAL
INTEREST IN HYPING THIS ENEMY
CONSTANTLY CREATING NEW PROGRAMS
AND BUREAUCRACIES THAT TAKE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
BUT SIMPLE SOLUTIONS TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE DEFENSE DON'T GENERATE
MUCH INTEREST IN WASHINGTON.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SUCH A GREAT
POINT ABOUT PAPER BALLOTS.
PEOPLE JUST WEREN'T -- I VAGUELY
REMEMBER THIS.
PEOPLE WERE NOT VERY INTERESTED
IN PROTECTING THE SYSTEM WITH
PAPER BALLOTS, WHICH WOULD DO
IT.
>> YEAH, I MEAN THAT WAS HER
POINT.
TULSI GABBARD WOULD SAY, ALL YOU
DO IS HEAR ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTION.
RUSSIAN HACKING OF OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM.
THERE'S A SIMPLE SOLUTION I
HAVE.
TWO PARAGRAPH BILL THAT JUST
REQUIRES STATES TO GENERATE
PAPER BALLOT BACKUPS SO NOBODY
CAN EVER HACK OUR VOTING
MACHINES BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE A
PAPER BACKUP TO PROVE IT.
I THINK SHE HAD LIKE FOUR
SPONSORS IN ALL OF CONGRESS
WHILE THEY WERE CONSTANTLY
BABBLING AROUND RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS.
SHOWS YOU THAT SO OFTEN THEY'RE
PRETEXT TO BUILD MASSIVE BUDGETS
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: IT'S TOTALLY AND
EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOUR POINT ABOUT OUR FOOD SUPPLY
IS OMINOUS AND TRUE.
THE BIGGEST BEE